Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. This is more perfect
a series about the cases that land in
front of the Supreme Court and in this
episode, which we might as
well call penny on part two.
We're going to take a deep dive into
what might be the most horrible supreme
court decision ever.
An attempt 160 years after the
fact in a Hilton hotel ballroom
to finally set it right.
[inaudible] do I know about the
USA? I know about the government.
Can you tell me about the constitution?
This is a case that split
the United States into
[inaudible] to the case in
question is the dred Scott Case,
which if you ask people,
I was wondering if you've ever
heard of the dread Scott Court case.
The dread Scott sounds
familiar, doesn't go well.
Nothing coming up, man. I don't know.
My high school history teacher
would be really mad at me right now.
I don't know. I don't remember
anything. I remember nothing.
We get a lot of people who are like,
what's that like a civil rights thing?
Probably something to do with segregation.
You're warm. I'm warm. What was it?
Obama like? The name had some
familiarity? Yes, yes. Straight. Okay,
that's great. What does that mean?
Dred Scott? It's a name. I don't know.
This is the first Emma here.
So what happens a lot of times is that
people don't actually understand why
they're free.
I'm so dred Scott is one of those
fundamental decisions that is,
that blazed the groundwork for the
reasons why we can live in a multicultural
society. This is Ellie, Ms
Doll. More perfect legal editor.
But to really understand the case,
you've got to go to a
place called Fort Snelling.
It's a small army base, about 15 minutes
north of the Minneapolis airport,
freshly laid on the
ground. And our producer,
Julia Longoria took a trip there
right over here. And this guy,
I'm Richard Josey,
manager of programs here at the Minnesota
historical society gave her a tour.
Yup. So what are we walking into now?
So what you're getting ready to see right
now is, uh, the space that we think,
you know, it's probably weird dreading
area. Scott, you know, where they live.
Before we go in. Can you just sort
of set up, when in time are we,
what's happening is the 1830s,
we're 30 years out from
the civil war, 1830s,
about half the states in the union
have slavery about half don't.
So it's this question that's kind of
still an answered like should we be a free
nation or should we be a slave nation?
So there is a real tension here and there
is a real understanding here that this
might not work. And just as we're
about to reach this breaking point,
an army doctor named John Emerson,
a white guy, definitely a white guy,
slave owner,
steps into free territory and arrived here
to this army base, um,
on a hill and he brings
with him his one slave,
dred Scott. Um, and now we're
actually inside the fortress,
if you will. And um, you
know, all of the stone,
all of the will windows, um, it's,
it's Kinda like whenever I come
here, I have this kinda cold feeling.
Even when it's hot outside,
he walks his up to the back of this one
squat building on the far end of the
base.
Can you describe the, the room?
I think we're probably looking at a
maybe seven and a half foot ceiling.
Um,
what grain floor? Wood clapboard
floor. Um, wood stone walls.
It's a tiny room. A little bigger
than a king bed. There's a fireplace,
little tables and redwood cabinets. So
this is, uh, this is a, this is a home.
This is a kitchen. This is a
laundry place. This is, you know,
your one stop shop.
Uh,
and the reason this room is so important
is because dred Scott living in this
room for the first time in
his life, he got a taste
[inaudible]
of what it might be
like to be free. I mean,
obviously he was still asleep,
but Dr. Emerson would leave the fort for
months at a time and have him work for
other people.
He had a degree of autonomy and Harriet
and dread met here, right? Yeah. Yeah.
When he was here, he met a girl,
1836, seven. Jeff, they met here.
Richard, Josie likes to stand here and
imagine just how that might've went down.
I can imagine, you know, Harriet, uh,
you know, haven't been here and uh,
and dread being over by the store and,
and having a conversation with some of
the other black guys that was here. And,
uh, I can imagine him saying,
did you see the new girl s here
is she comes walking by Geo?
Who is that? I'm going to make her mind
like, I can imagine him saying
that over the next few years,
dred and Harriet had two kids, both
of them girls. And I personally,
I think that what happened was
children seem to change everything.
[inaudible]
so what ends up happening is that Dr.
Emerson moves dred Scott and his family
back to Missouri.
They're back in a slave state and
Dr. Emerson ends up passing away
[inaudible]
and it seems like his wife is gonna
maybe sell dred Scott's daughters.
So what
dred and Harriet Scott
ended up deciding to do.
The whole reason we know dread Scott's
name is that they decide to sue for their
own freedom.
That's a lawsuit that dred Scott had
every right to believe that he would win.
There was a doctrine called
once free, always free,
that the minute your foot
landed in the snow of the north,
the minute you and your owner
walked into free territory,
you were free and you could not
be returned to a state of bondage.
This was a well known
legal argument and in fact,
dred Scott won at a lower court.
So it goes all the way up to the Supreme
Court and the Supreme Court says,
no, you're still property. And the
chief justice of the Supreme Court,
Roger Tawny,
very famously, he says, the
black man has no rights,
that the white man is bound to respect
tawny in a amazingly broad decision,
not only slams the door
on dred Scott's freedom,
he slams the door on the potential for
any African American free or not free to
ever have full citizenship
in this country.
And at that point in time at the
highest court of the land to make that
decision.
That was putting a period on sort of
this overarching battle between um,
the north and the south. The for
slavery and the abolition is,
and so when this happens,
now you start seeing civil war popping up
[inaudible]
now as far as dred Scott, that case
is concerned, but speaking legally,
the 13th and 14th amendments did come
along and overturn it. But like that line,
like the black man has no rights
that a white man is bound to respect.
Like you can't overturn that
line. And these days, you know,
as depending on swings
and we see a rise in
blatant,
overt white nationalism more than scream
does when people injured and violence
over statues. This car plowed into
a crowd of people. But that line
still hovers above us all.
But suppose you're a direct descendant
of that case, of that history.
Suppose your name is Scott,
your last name is tawny.
What do you do with that particularly now?
Like what do you do with that
history? Do you ignore it?
Is it not your problem or do you
address it? And if you do, how
coming up next after the break we walk
into a hotel lobby in St Louis and get an
answer. We just did not expect
[inaudible]
or perfect. We'll continue in a moment.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
I'm Preet Bharara every
weekend. My podcast, stay tuned.
I answer your questions about what's
really happening in Washington.
I wonder if it is legal for president
Trump to initiate north hairy action
against North Korea. What
happens if Mueller returns?
I'm indictment again, the president.
I just want to know are
you a stable genius?
Subscribe to stay tuned
from cafe and W NYC studios.
This is more perfect. I'm
Chad. I boom Rod. Okay.
Now we come to the reunion as she was
reporting this story producer Julia
Longoria is doing a little googling,
located a couple of Scott
Tawny descendants and then
found out that they were
actually planning to meet up to
have this kind of historic summit,
which was like, we thought it was bananas.
So she went and it was bananas.
And as soon as she came back she sat
down in the studio and told Elly Ms Doll
and I all about it. Um, so where to start?
[inaudible] so I locked into this
Hilton Frontenac hotel in St Louis?
No, your classic hotel atrium.
With like a very weird
carpet pattern like,
and I walk in and it's like, oh, drove
in or you, it's almost like a conference
and I'm greeted by the great,
great granddaughter of Dred Scott. Wow.
And uh, yeah, it's just amazing. I mean,
literally this is our inaugural sons
and daughters of reconciliation events.
Names Lynn Jackson.
She's the main organizer.
This was always a dream that I
had about 12 years ago. There's,
I couldn't meet other descendants.
Wouldn't that be cool?
Then she immediately tells me,
I'm a networker. I'm a networker.
I'm going to connect you with everyone
here. That's what I like doing.
And this is a blow family right here.
And immediately she introduces me to
these three people. What's your name?
Mimi laboratoire.
John Lavar Schwab mashed in the bourgeois
one who are descendants of the blow
family, the first family who
owned her. Great. Great Grandpa.
Here's some more fun gas.
Hello guys. Come on in.
She also introduced me to the
great, great, great, great, great.
Sixth grade grandson. Thomas Jefferson.
Yeah. Grandson of Thomas Jefferson.
I met, what's your name?
I'm Bertram Hayes Davis.
Hyphenate at descendant
of Jefferson Davis.
You know the guy who led the confederacy
against the union in the civil war and
everybody's hugging and laughing.
It was wild. Almost like,
it sounds like almost like a
meaning of the Utopian society. Yes,
exactly. And the whole idea, everyone
kind of wanted reconciliation,
reconciliation, reconciliation.
That was like the word of the day,
reconciliation,
reconciliation. So the nation,
I think they got a lot of the
country needs that now. You know,
so I think a lot of people here and so
I'm wandering around and reading these
people, like going up, shaking
hands with random people.
And then I meet this one guy,
Scott Madison. Lynn introduced us.
Oh yes, your name dread
Madison. I'm the great,
great grandson of dread and Harry Scott.
And I look in his eyes and I was like,
Holy Shit. Those are dred Scott's eyes.
I mean,
there's really only one picture of dred
Scott that exists and it's from around
1857 he's wearing a suit staring straight
at the camera and his eyes are like
almost glassy. Ms Pupils are
really big. And it's just striking.
I felt like I was looking
bright into those same eyes.
And have you always known that you're
related to dread Scott? I imagine? Yes.
And what, what's your relationship
to that history? What do you,
when you think about it, what
do you, what do you feel?
I have mixed feelings
based on what [inaudible]
chief justice tardy said and
the decision they made. A,
you are subhuman species
with no rights, a whiteness
boundary respect. Blacks have no rights
that white men are bound to respect.
That still resonates today in my opinion.
[inaudible]
what really hit me the hardest, and I,
I it's hard meeting with
think about this cause it,
it just bothers me was the
Trayvon Martin right on the line,
a teenager was shot
down by one name or one,
one self defense. This kid was walking
home from school, from a store,
wasn't bothering, wasn't breaking any
laws. Someone decided to follow him,
pull up on him and he ended up
murdering him. That guy parked his car,
got out of his car,
invaded the show me a space and murdered
him and used to stand your ground law.
And that's a perfect example
of Ma, your ground is yours.
Until I decided it's not.
I meet dread just as he is about to
shake hands for the first time with the
family who owned his family. A whole lot
of stuff that goes through your mind.
Are they going to be, are
they going to be buddy heads?
I think arrogance did that all
go through your head, but you,
you know you have to approach people.
You have to approach
people for who they are.
You've got to have open mind and one of
the most striking things I learned from
dread Scott Junior, junior and
also from my sister Barbara,
I'm Barbara McGregory,
I'm dread. Scott's great,
great granddaughter is that the dred
Scott history was actually something that
was kind of kept from them.
It was hush hush thing because
the dred Scott decision,
I don't know if you are
understanding what that was,
that that was the last straw that
sparked the civil war. My Dad,
when they were growing up,
they had death strips, right?
So they couldn't tell anybody who
they were related to your dad.
That generation.
This was like a hundred years after the
decision that generation had to keep it
a secret. That's his great
grandfather. His grandmother was dread.
Scott's daughter, great
dread junior. Junior,
junior told me that his dad was
actually partially raised by dread.
Scott's daughter, Lizzy,
whose name was Lizzie,
try to hide the fact. In
fact, someone told me she was,
she might've been kind
of mad when, um, my, uh,
grandfather and grandmother named my
father dred Scott because she was in
hiding. You gotta remember when
she was, uh, six years old.
They wouldn't hiding for five years
during the trial earner sister because the
whole basis of trial was he
didn't want his family split up.
So when he lost the second appeal,
he sent the girls into hiding because
he didn't want them sold away.
So Lizzy stayed pretty much undercover.
She lived in a, a little, little room,
but she always had the shades close,
so dread. And Barbara told me their
parents never talked about dred Scott.
They never had a picture up in the house.
They never even knew what he looked like.
In fact, as we were standing there
in the lobby of the Hilton, dread,
pulls out his phone photos
of dred Scott. Okay.
Pictures of dred Scott. And he
brings up the photo on Google.
That's the actual photographs. That's
the actual photograph, which looks,
let's see. Looks like this. That's
it. Yeah. So can you describe it?
Uh, really dark eyes.
Um, he's wearing a suit.
Like he was impressed, I think. Like you
wouldn't expect a slave to be dressed.
So Nice. Wait, is that the first time
you've seen the picture of dred Scott? No,
it's not the first time,
but it seemed like he was noticing
things in it for the first time.
It looks really dignified and stern
in that picture, but he looks,
he looks like a man who's going through
it and is ready to go through some more.
He does.
[inaudible]
[inaudible] she has to have a
separate project. Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
So at the end of the night, I ended up
at the hotel bar with another descendant,
so I let her answer that.
Uh, no, I think you should answer that. So
the dred Scott Case is a famous supreme
court case and the chief justice who
ruled in that case was named
Roger Protonix. And so I'm a tiny
Charlie Tani is the great, great
grand nephew of Roger Brooke. Tony,
who is the chief justice who basically
denied dred Scott his freedom, right?
He's kind of a tall guy. White hair. I'll
take one more topic. Okay. Glasses on.
Tip of his nose. You know,
we had an 11 about original copy of that
decision and he was actually sitting
next to three descendants from the
family who originally owned dread Scott.
They were like, come join us.
And so to my left is the descendant of
the people who own dread Scott into my
right are the people who
kept dred Scott and slaved,
are you not going to eat one of those?
And they were all just like
having gin and tonics and crap.
Kate's outlet strategy.
Remember that father
says you have never dad.
It's not even as packs.
That's great. Can you,
can you describe the first
images you saw of Tony?
Eventually I steer the conversation
back to Charlie. Tanya's ancestor,
Roger Tawny. The Supreme Court
justice? Well, we had, we had, uh,
we have pictures of them hanging on
our hat on. I grew up in the house.
It was up on the wall and it had, I
remember it had this a light over it,
unlike the dread Scott family,
Charlie Tawny and his daughter Kate,
Kate Tani Billingsley grew up knowing
exactly what Roger looks like.
His skin flapped over and
he had these long jowls,
but he was also a thin
man. He was very sickly.
That's something I really recall.
He looks like, um, spooked me.
That shriveled up little, okay
man who lives up in the house on the
hill that hardly ever comes out of his
house. And all the kids are scared
of you grew up, man, you know,
in the once the first time you study the
civil war, probably like fifth grade,
sixth grade,
and you're like sliding down in your
seat when they get to the dred Scott
decision because you know, this is
really terrible. And that's my family.
And I'm like, God, they did that. So
that you're very aware of it. Yeah.
And we're also, I mean, and we're
also, you know, while while you're, um,
well that's a black mark on our family.
He also ran one of the most productive
courts and it was during a time of
explosive growth in the country.
So we're very proud of his
role and helping form America.
What he's known for is the single worst
decision ever made by the Supreme Court.
If you're a family member,
it's, it's, um, a little,
a little difficult to have
that be the only focus
fully sitting there.
It was pretty clear that Charlie Tawny
was kind of like dread. Scott Madison.
He also had some mixed feelings.
Well, having read, having read a
number of his letters, I, you know,
I think he was, I think, you know, he,
I think he really loved his wife and his
family and I think he was a very loving
father and he was against
slavery is pretty clear.
He thought it was a blot
on the national character.
He thought slavery was wrong. Are
we talking about tiny still? Yeah.
He, yeah, he felt it was wrong and
should eventually be just done away with.
He told me that in one
of his legal arguments,
tawny totally railed against
slave drivers. He said
something to the effect of,
uh, these people are reptiles who deal
in the trafficking of human flesh.
Sitting there,
Charlie tells me that Roger Tawny
was trying to save the Union,
that somehow if he ruled that America
was a slave ocracy once and for all
really, that might somehow
delay the civil war
and he was trying to solve the issue of
slavery in America. That might be true,
but you can't look for, look yes.
When you read that language
that he was a stone racist,
I mean just was,
and um, and I asked them like,
when you met the Scott's like, what
did you feel like, what did you,
did you feel like you wanted to
communicate something to them?
And the blow descendant, you know,
the family who originally
owned dred Scott said, yeah,
like we're sorry. And I
was like, have you ever,
I turned to Tanya and said like,
have you ever actually apologized?
And he was like, I don't know.
I don't know if I ever use those words.
I don't recall ever using those words.
[inaudible]
[inaudible] next day.
Well, welcome to the drags car
reconciliation forum. I know,
well these two at the forum,
about a hundred people crammed into
the grand ballroom of the Hilton and a
preacher, so to forget into
median today in our proceedings,
I'd like to ask if you'd stand with me
and go to the Lord repaired the blessed
these proceedings today. Let the
group in prayer. Heavenly father,
we come to you this day seeking your
blessings in this room and we ask,
Lord that this reconciliation would
begin today in a profound way each of our
hearts as we learn from our
past to move to our future
Les Esis Day and board, we give
you praise. In Jesus name we pray.
Amen. You may be, see at this time,
we would like for all of
the descendants if you will,
to please just stand with these
descendants. Get up on stage.
Thank you and good morning everyone
one by one. I'm so happy to be here.
As part of the reconciliation conference
and they keep like a little schpiel
about, oh, thank you so much. Thank you.
They are what reconciliation
means to them.
And a lot of people don't know
the Thomas Jefferson's wife.
Martha is the half sister of Sally Hemet.
Things you might not know about
their ancestors. They had,
they had the same father John Wells.
After about five people had spoken.
Please welcome Charlie for the stage.
Charlie Tani got up to talk morning. So
the first thing I like to do is tell
you all how glad I am to be here.
Real honor and privilege to be here. So
let me start with Roger Burke. Tonya,
what it was like to grow up as somebody
to grow up as a tawny in terms of how we
feel about him. It's a
real, it's a mixed bag.
It's a very mixed thing because
on the one hand, as a tiny,
you're proud of him.
He was one of the longest serving
chief justices, the Bible.
He swore Lincoln and with,
it's the same Bible that
President Obama was sworn in on.
However, that's not what he's known for.
What he's known for is one thing he's
done for the dred Scott decision.
And just so we all want
to get a handle on that.
Let me read you a sentence that he wrote
was his opinion at the
time of the constitution
that African-Americans,
here's the quote for more than a
century had been regarded as beans of an
inferior ordering
unfit to associate with white,
the right race so far inferior.
They had no rights, which the
white man was bound to respect.
So you might be proud of him
but you can't talk that
you can talk about.
So, uh, I looked up reconciliation,
I lift up this morning the
process of reconciliation
and there are three steps.
The first step is apology.
The second step is forgiveness.
And the third step is a new
trust. It grows out of that.
But some, someone asks Kate about this
issue, apology. And what Kate said was,
my daughter said, well, she
said, you know, autonomy,
bringing an apology to a Scott is like
bringing a bandaid to an amputation.
It just, it is not
enough. But he was like,
you got to start somewhere. So let's let
them, let's make a little history today
on the tonics. So all the scotch
you have our apologies. Nope.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
I spoke to Scott descendants afterwards.
How was that? What did you of that?
I'm still
emotion. Very much more emotional
than I thought. That's great.
Great granddaughter, Barbara
Gregory. No one's ever apologize.
Clinton made an apology some years ago,
but coming from him didn't mean much.
But here when tawny got emotional,
when he was reading that letters,
that was more heartfelt
to me than anything else.
The apology was okay, but, but
his emotion really touched me.
Barbara, that dred Scott
descendant was like
when he choked up reading
that I could feel that like,
that felt like healing.
You're doing hello.
Then I pull aside her brother and I
ask you what you're thinking about.
How did you respond to all of that? Dread,
Scott Madison, the one with the eyes,
everything was fine. It's just,
ah, to be honest, the last part,
pupil was Catholic. Uh, I didn't like it.
I don't think somebody should
have to apologize for something.
They didn't do this. I just,
I was very uncomfortable with that.
That's the fact that they're here.
Is apology enough apologizing
for something your ancestor did?
You're part of a gene pool. Usually
you're judged by your works,
not someone else's. Show me that you care.
Don't tell me that you're sorry. Tell
me that you're going to do better.
That's the only
couple of final notes. When we
talked to dread Scott Madison later,
he was pretty clear that like Charlie
Tawny is already doing a lot of good.
He's helping the dred Scott
Foundation to raise money.
That's why he felt the trail. He
didn't need to apologize. Also,
when we started the story,
there were statues of Roger Book
Tawny in Annapolis and in Baltimore,
both in front of courthouses.
This is actually how the town is and
Scott's one of the first ways that they'd
come together.
They had decided collectively on a plan
to amend those two statues rather than
take them down.
They had decided to put a dread Scott
statue next to them that had been the
plan. They'd been working on it.
They had met with politicians.
They've met with the mayor of Baltimore,
but then as we were
finishing up the story,
good morning, Maryland begins now with
breaking news. Charlottesville happened,
and in the wake of Charlottesville,
and we certainly do have some breaking
news that's more than Roger Brooke Tawny
statue is no longer standing outside
the Maryland State House in Annapolis.
It's the latest dementia of a pro
slavery icon to come down in the wake of
violent racial clashes in
Charlottesville, Virginia. Yes.
Both statutes were taken
down in the same, yeah,
it was really, it was really
weird out here, I have to say,
in about 25 to people out
here, here's what happened.
They started the rope off the street
and then at 1220 they started and they
hoisted tawny up.
There was a golf clam when Tawney came
off the pedestal here and was removed.
But other than that, everybody was
quiet. Nobody had an opinion on this.
And if they did, they
kept it to themselves.
Heart and 45 year history gone here
tonight, and I'll get out of the way.
This is all this left. This
is the pedestal that is left
[inaudible],
Eh,
[inaudible] [inaudible]
oh, Yay.
[inaudible] more perfect is produced
by me. Jad Abumrad, Susie Lichtenberg,
Jenny Lawton, Julia Longoria, Kelly
primes Saraj Karrie, Sean Roms from,
and Alex Overington.